este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
internet un servicio de almacenamiento
en la nube muy pero que muy interesante
quedaos con este nombre inter next
arranquemos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
asia-pacífico se ha convertido en la
región más importante del mundo y tal y
como ya os hemos contado en la pugna por
el control entre eeuu y sus aliados y
china no sólo importa quién tiene más o
menos bases militares sino también quién
emplea mejor sus armas y sabe sacar
mejor provecho de los nuevos avances
tecnológicos esta es de hecho una
carrera paralela a la propia escalada
militar que está viviendo la región y si
puede que eeuu siga muy por delante pero
amigos los chinos tienen sus propias
cartas
[Música]
históricamente el ejército chino ha
tenido serios problemas para equiparse
con armas avanzadas que he llegado el
caso le permitirá enfrentarse de tú a tú
con enemigos tan fuertes como los eeuu
precisamente por eso para suplir esa
limitación la estrategia de china ha
pasado esencialmente por una apuesta por
la cantidad esto es por disponer de un
número muy grande de tropas que le
permitirá proteger sus fronteras actuar
como disuasión ante cualquier posible
ataque y operar en un terreno próximo
[Música]
es algo que vimos en cierta forma
durante la guerra de korea cuando un
enorme ejército formado por unos 800.000
voluntarios chinos fueron a la guerra
para ayudar a las tropas del dictador
norcoreano kim son claro que en la
guerra moderna una guerra dominada por
la comunicación los satélites y los
ataques quirúrgicos la cantidad ha ido
perdiendo cada vez más y más relevancia
ojo hablo de la guerra no de la
posguerra eso como se vio en irak o en
afganistán es una cuestión muy diferente
el caso es que con rivales
tecnológicamente tan avanzados como
estados unidos corea del sur japón o
australia el ejército chino no le ha
quedado otra que ponerse las pilas el
ejército popular de liberación lleva
años inmerso en un proceso de cambio
cuyo objetivo es darle la vuelta de
arriba abajo transitar desde la idea del
soldado como corazón del ejército a la
tecnología como núcleo esencial de las
fuerzas armadas la fecha para lograrlo
también está fijada el año 2000 49 pero
evidentemente no hay recursos para todo
de hecho ya os contábamos en un pasado
vídeo que la diferencia de presupuesto
militar entre los eeuu y china puede ser
mucho más grande de lo que pensamos a
primera vista así que en otras palabras
los líderes chinos han tenido que
escoger en qué tipo de guerra quieren
destacar así que la pregunta que casi
todos segurosseguros estás haciendo es
por dónde van los tiros cuáles son
exactamente los tipos de armas con las
que los líderes chinos aspiran a tener
la hegemonía de asia-pacífico qué
demonios tienen en mente
básicamente el régimen chino está
apostando por la superioridad aérea
convencional mediante las tecnologías de
sigilo así como por las conocidas como
armas de nuevo concepto las armas del
nuevo concepto es una tipología de
armamento que a su vez se divide en tres
grandes subgrupos primero las armas de
energía dirigida como las tecnologías de
pulso electromagnético o las armas láser
segundo las armas de información como
son los vídeos informáticos y los
sistemas de hackeo y tercero las armas
biológicas o químicas como es el caso
por ejemplo de las desarrolladas con
virus editados genéticamente
hey stop que ella se lo que estáis
pensando no esto último no es en
absoluto ninguna referencia al sars con
hábitos que nos conocemos
[Música]
pues bien el caso es que los científicos
militares chinos llevan años trabajando
en todos y cada uno de estos tres campos
con una idea crear un novedoso sistema
militar que sea capaz de atacar de la
forma más eficiente multiplicar los
daños e incluso ser invisible muchos de
vosotros quizás nunca hayáis oído hablar
de algunas de las armas que os vamos a
mostrar porque no este vídeo no va de
portaaviones ni fragatas tanques ni de
ninguna otra cosa que recuerde
esencialmente al siglo 20 atentos
un momento antes de continuar con el
vídeo me gustaría hablaros de internet
[Música]
como sabéis en visual política
trabajamos con mucha muchísima
documentación nos preocupa mucho la
seguridad y la privacidad por eso esta
empresa nos ha llamado muchísimo la
atención internet es un servicio de
almacenamiento en la nube que no sólo te
permite organizar mejor tus documentos
sino que además es mucho más seguro que
los servicios en la nube de las big tex
pero cuál es la diferencia pues veréis
internet encriptar todos tus datos y no
guardar tu clave de encriptación para
que nos entendamos esto significa que
solo tú tienes acceso a tus datos nadie
más interesante nos parecen internet
quiere convertirse en una alternativa
para almacenar datos en la nube centrada
sobre todo en la seguridad y la
confidencialidad de toda tu información
y además tienen varios planes de
suscripción que se adaptan a las
necesidades de cada usuario pero sabéis
que es lo mejor que sólo por haber visto
este vídeo si este vídeo tendrás un mes
gratis al suscribirte a su plan de dos
terabytes así que no pierdas la
oportunidad de probar internet con esta
oferta exclusiva introduciendo el cupón
visual político cuando elijas tu plan os
dejamos el enlace a su web abajo en la
descripción dicho esto
continuemos
las armas de energía dirigida
seguro seguro que todos habéis oído
hablar de las armas láser me juego un
brazo que si es una idea que puede
parecer sacada de star wars pero que ya
existe en el mundo militar y que en
diferentes fases experimentales está ya
siendo probada por ejércitos como los de
eeuu rusia y si también china sin
embargo las armas láser son tan sólo uno
de los tipos de armas que podemos
encontrar dentro de una categoría más
amplia la de las armas de energía
dirigida
las armas de energía dirigida son un
tipo de armas de última generación que
utilizan proyectiles que no son sólidos
como por ejemplo láser o plasma o dicho
de otra forma no disparan proyectiles
tal y como los conocemos normalmente lo
que tiene importantes ventajas por un
lado potencialmente pueden ser mucho más
baratas una vez son producidas porque no
necesitan munición y por otro lado hoy
por hoy el ataque no puede ser detenido
por ningún tipo de escudo de sistema
además son armas muy precisas que
generan menos deflagraciones y daños
colaterales
el problema que debido precisamente a
estos factores bajo coste y alta
dificultad para evitar el ataque son
también armas más peligrosas que las
convencionales especialmente si en el
futuro consiguen dar el salto evolutivo
que los ejércitos de las grandes
potencias están buscando
[Música]
en el caso de china en 2017 el país voy
a conocer un sistema de armas láser
llamado silent hunter que he traducido
al español significa cazador silencioso
este sistema ha sido desarrollado por la
empresa poly technologies perteneciente
al grupo empresarial público pineapple y
group corporation el artefacto consta de
un cañón láser montado sobre un camión y
alimentado por electricidad utilizando
la máxima potencia el laser llega a
tener un alcance de 4 kilómetros sin
apenas perder efectividad destructiva
para que os hagáis una idea de su
potencia es capaz de penetrar cinco
placas de acero de dos milímetros de
grosor cada una a 800 metros de
distancia o una sola placa de 5
milímetros si hablamos de un kilómetro
esto traducido a la vida real implicaría
que en distancias cortas el silent
hunter sería capaz de comprometer
incluso a vehículos blindados ligeros en
un hipotético a la vez que improbable
combate terrestre
ahora bien la pregunta clave para qué
demonios quiere china este sistema pues
en principio no parece que la idea sea
ofensiva sino más bien todo lo contrario
aunque con matices porque bueno la
enemistad entre india y china podría
terminar haciendo la protagonista pero
no nos desviemos por un lado este láser
podría ser enormemente útil como defensa
anti drones de baja altura siempre y
cuando no olvidemos que con un alcance
de un kilómetro la máxima potencia y que
los drones militares más avanzados
pueden volar a unos 15.000 metros de
altura este láser tiene hoy por hoy una
aplicación muy limitada en materia
defensiva
[Música]
según pekín por ahora su utilidad pasa
por proteger instalaciones sensibles o
incluso eventos multitudinarios del bolo
de drones no utilizados drones que por
ejemplo pudieran suponer una amenaza
terrorista aunque lo cierto es que en
alguna ocasión los eeuu ya se han
quejado de que china ha utilizado este u
otro sistema similar para apuntar a los
pilotos estadounidenses de aviones c-130
hércules mientras volaban en yibutí
donde china tiene su única base militar
en el extranjero causando con ello
heridas menores en los ojos de algunos
de estos pilotos
ensayos sea como sea y tenga el futuro
que tenga este arma láser no es la única
arma de energía dirigida que china está
desarrollando fijaos china podría haber
probado una nueva arma electromagnética
pero qué diantres es esto de un
artefacto
electromagnético exactamente pues bien
hay dos formas principales de usar la
fuerza electromagnética en la guerra una
más espectacular que otra y en ambos
tipos china ha logrado ya importantes
avances
por un lado están los ataques de pulso
electromagnético que mediante el envío
de un pulso similar a cuando se produce
una fuerte llamarada solar son capaces
de poner en jaque todo el sistema
eléctrico de un país así como todo
aquello que utilice electricidad o
geoposicionamiento no esto no es ninguna
teoría conspiranoica ni ninguna idea
alocada es la realidad pero como creéis
que se podría conseguir de forma
artificial esta energía electromagnética
tan descomunal alguna idea
pues por ejemplo mediante armas
nucleares concretamente a través de una
tecnología particular de misiles y la
tecnología de la bomba de hidrógeno o
termonuclear se puede conseguir provocar
un enorme pulso electromagnético si se
detonan a gran altitud sobre el lugar
del ataque
en teoría este tipo de ataques no tienen
los efectos negativos y destructivos de
un ataque nuclear convencional pero el
caos que pueden llegar a provocar es
inmenso china tiene la capacidad de un
primer golpe que funda la red eléctrica
de eeuu con un arma tipo pulso
electromagnético impresionados pues
espera a ver lo que es capaz de hacer
china desde un simple barco los
protagonistas los cañones de riel
electromagnético
[Música]
y los que más sabes de esto diréis pero
alberto si esto no es nada nuevo y es
verdad la idea conceptual es bastante
antigua data de la segunda guerra
mundial de hecho tenemos un vídeo
dedicado al tema en nuestro canal de
mega project echadle un ojo a diferencia
entre los de esa época y los actuales es
su aplicación y obviamente sus mejoras
en fuerza y precisión en el caso de
china en 2018 ha aparecido en wuhan un
enorme cañón de rey electromagnético
montado en la proa del buque high
yangxiang
este tipo de armand no es exactamente
una arma de energía dirigida ya que
dispara un proyectil pero lo hace
montando lo en dos rieles conductores
paralelos cargados con una cantidad
enorme de electricidad lo que crea un
campo magnético esto permite que el
proyectil salga del cañón a velocidades
supersónicas gracias a la fuerza de
laurent de esta forma multiplica la
destrucción en blancos con cinturones
acorazados como por ejemplo son los
buques de guerra
precisamente por esto china lo ha
probado a bordo de un barco pekín cree
que este arma le puede dar superioridad
naval a su marina y claro evidentemente
una superioridad numérica y también
tecnológica es clave para que china
pueda cumplir su sueño de controlar los
mares de la región asia-pacífico sobre
todo el de la china meridional ahora
bien llegados a este punto seguro que os
estáis preguntando por el resto de armas
de las que os íbamos a hablar en este
vídeo pues bien vamos allá
la guerra del futuro está en el aire
os acordáis del mítico bombardero
estadounidense
f-117 nighthawk este avión tan extraño
que cautivó a los amantes de la aviación
militar y cuya principal característica
era ser el primer bombardero invisible
del mundo apuesto a que sí pues bien la
tecnología del sigilo ya no es algo tan
exclusivo de hecho muchos países con
programas más o menos potentes de
desarrollo de aviones militares ya han
adoptado esta tecnología total o
parcialmente y si china también es uno
de ellos
[Música]
este es el caso del caza chendu j-20 que
es y las sinuosas formas geométricas del
f-117 es también un avión invisible o
furtivo de quinta generación o al menos
eso es lo que decía pequeña hasta hace
poco la cuestión es que este es el
primer caza con tecnología de sigilo
desarrollado íntegramente en el gigante
asiático un caza diseñado supuestamente
para competir con otros tres cazas
furtivos avanzados que están actualmente
en servicio los f-22 y f-35
estadounidenses y el psuc hoy 57 rusos
hoy por hoy sin embargo son muchos
expertos en la materia los que coinciden
en que el j-20 no reúne los requisitos
necesarios como para ser considerado un
caza de quinta generación sino que se
situaría en algún punto entre la cuarta
generación y la 4.5 en cualquier caso lo
que más se discute sobre este aparato no
es eso sino cómo se desarrolló
concretamente existen muchas sospechas
de que tiene detrás toda una historia de
espionaje militar a los programas
estadounidenses de los cazas f-35 y f-22
si tal cual como lo es
[Música]
lockheed martin la compañía
desarrolladora de estos dos modelos está
convencida de que hackers chinos robaron
documentos técnicos del f-35 en 2007 y
también penetraron en la red de un
subcontratista australiano del programa
también están seguros de que el modelo
chino incluye tecnología robada del
programa efe 22 ahora bien en que se
basan pues bien según fuentes
estadounidenses el sistema de sensores
del j-20 es casi clavado al tlc 22 y no
sólo eso parece copiar el f-35 en cosas
tan importantes como el radar con las
calibraciones del motor el robo de
tecnología militar occidental por parte
de china ha sido durante mucho tiempo
más que una sospecha prácticamente un
secreto a voces en este caso incluso
edwards nou den que no está precisamente
bien visto por el gobierno de los eeuu
confirma que efectivamente china robó
muchos terabytes de datos de información
clasificada sobre el f-35
nuevos documentos desnuden revelan que
los chinos están detrás del hackeo al
f-35 amigos uno de los sueños militares
que pekín siempre ha tenido es romper la
brecha aéreas con eeuu
hoy por hoy los expertos consideran que
las características de este avión son
muy inferiores a las de sus competidores
norteamericanos y que no tiene la
capacidad de ganar en un enfrentamiento
abierto eso sí su propia evolución
supone un paso adelante decisivo para la
industria militar china es por así
decirlo su primera gran incursión en el
campo de los gigantes del aire
una incursión con una importante ventaja
sin el f-35 para taiwán podría resultar
muy complicado contener un ataque masivo
con este avión precisamente por eso las
autoridades taiwanesas llevan años
pidiendo eeuu que les permitan comprar
el f-35 pero la respuesta de los
americanos ha sido para no dar largas o
hablar de un leasing que bueno pues de
momento no llega
las ventas de aviones de combate a
taiwán y el complejo equilibrio de poder
entre estados unidos y china taiwán
quería cazas f-35 con capacidad de
aterrizaje y despegue vertical corto
para preservar su capacidad de aérea en
caso de sufrir ataques sorpresas del
ejército popular de liberación sobre
aeródromos taiwaneses que inhabilitar a
las pistas estos intentos por negociar
la venta sin embargo se vieron
obstaculizados por la administración de
obama en su lugar ofreció el paquete de
actualización del f-16 a taiwán no hay
forma parece que washington no quiere
abrir el melón político que se pondría
que taipei tuviera sus propios cazas
f-35 de momento la respuesta americana
ha sido mover de vez en cuando
portaaviones a la zona cargados con
estos aviones pero los taiwaneses no
obtienen la seguridad de que ante un
ataque real chino eeuu llegar a entrar
en combate y por ese motivo lógicamente
quieren tener sus propios f-35 pero ojo
porque el caza a chengdu jota mente no
es la única amenaza sigilosa china
china también está trabajando en el
desarrollo de un avanzado modelo de
drone el wj 700 junto con el dron
invisible skyhawk chino podría realizar
reconocimientos en entornos hostiles y
luego atacar desde gran altitud el wj
700 es un salto cualitativo brutal en el
programa de drones chinos ya que es el
único drone de gran altitud alta
velocidad y largo rango capaz de
ejecutar misiones de ataque en concreto
puede realizar ataques de precisión aire
superficie en múltiples situaciones algo
que lo pone casi a la altura de los
drones estadounidenses más modernos
la ventaja que le daría este tipo de
armas a pekín para operar en el
extranjero podría cambiar en el futuro
la estrategia militar y diplomática de
pekín en fin solo el tiempo dirá amigas
y amigos de visual político estas son
sólo unas pocas de las muchas nuevas
armas con las que china quiere dar el
golpe en la mesa en el futuro hay
muchísimas más de todas las formas y
colores incluido un sistema de guerra
espacial
y si lo habéis escuchado bien china está
desarrollando un sistema asad de
destrucción de satélites mediante
cohetes espaciales una capacidad que ya
tenía la unión soviética durante la
guerra fría y luego están los temas de
los virus modificados genéticamente o
las ciberguerras ámbitos de los que
seguro hablaremos más adelante
china sigue muy lejos de eeuu y
evidentemente los norteamericanos tienen
sus propios programas de armas
tecnológicamente avanzadas pero la
apuesta china está sobre la mesa y en
ella las armas de energía dirigida los
cazas de quinta generación y los drones
avanzados juegan un papel clave también
en los misiles supersónicos con los que
las fuerzas armadas chinas esperan dejar
fuera de combate por obsoleta a la
mismísima marina norteamericana
china prueba nueva capacidad espacial
con misiles hipersónicos el lanzamiento
en agosto de cohetes con capacidad
nuclear dio la vuelta al mundo y tomó
por sorpresa la inteligencia
estadounidense pero dicho esto turno
para ti crees que china logrará
equipararse a la fuerza de eeuu en asia
pacifico déjanos tu comentario por aquí
abajo y si te ha gustado este vídeo no
olvides darle a like y suscribirte avisa
al político si aún no lo has hecho una
vez más gracias por estar ahí un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]